foreign
Huntsville Alabama hi Daniel welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave Rachel
it's great to be honest yeah good to
have you how can we help
well so uh got kind of a conundrum at
our house
um I've accepted a new job about eight
hours away
um and I start this Monday I left my
previous job about two weeks ago so I
made a two-week period there of just
kind of being home together and getting
the house kind of set up and uh
my plan is that I'm going to be leaving
this weekend heading to the new job
using her my wife's brother's spare room
for a couple weeks and then looking for
a place to rent uh while we're in uh and
letting them stay here and finish uh
school year and stuff like that but
there's some apprehension from my wife
about about the move and uh she's she's
kind of feeling like we're really set up
well here and um not wanting to move the
kids and worried about uh interest rates
and stuff like that for the purchase of
a new home
I'm a little bit confused why didn't we
discuss all this for you took the
freaking job
well you know
we kind of did uh
it seemed like a good idea it's a good
time for that time and I it's for me
it's a promotion
um it's a pay raise it's a bonus
increase and it's actually moving uh
back home for us uh to an area that
we're from so there's lots of family
around and everything
um and the the kids are actually seem to
be pretty pretty excited about it or at
least my son who's six years old he's
excited to go be mural his little
cousins
um
her biggest uh what what is her number
one reason is it the kids is it interest
rates because all of this can be fixed
or does she have a life in Huntsville
that she loves and she doesn't want to
leave
uh and there's not a life in Huntsville
that that run a little bit
um she likes kids school that they go to
and we send them to a private school
here
um she's uncertain about schools in the
area that we're going to um which but
their schools that we went to and and
came from again I don't understand why
y'all didn't discuss this before
I think none of that has changed
you didn't take this job and half talk
to her
well no I mean like we we talked about
it I um
you know I'd try to paint the picture of
once I got the job offer because I went
to the interview and once I got the job
offer with the raise and the bonus
um of what we could do because we could
we're gonna uh we have a lot of equity
in our I mean but she didn't raise these
concerns then
not not exactly no uh or at least she
says I I didn't want to listen to him
um
knows that that's that's kind of what
I'm thinking
like you bulldozed this and now you're
paying for it
did I miss something yeah yeah no no
oh Daniel oh no man okay well you got I
mean you start Monday so you're gonna
have to make some you're gonna have to
make some decisions you guys are gonna
have to have a come to Jesus meeting and
and you have to lay out I mean she needs
to lay out all of her concerns where
she's frustrated with you if you didn't
really listen to that and own that
um you guys look at the schools do re
like like get as much information as
possible because interest rates I mean
whatever rent for a year and we just
hadn't yeah interest rates I wouldn't do
that and there's school there's schools
everywhere I understand people love
their school I love where our kids are
but if you had to move for a job there's
great schools in every city that you can
find right like I mean for the most part
yeah so all of that can be overcome my
my issue though Daniel is that that that
um the problems that she's bringing up
can be solvable but I think she's
probably thinking holy crap you just
went and did all this and I and I may
not I may not be on board
yeah um how old are you guys
uh 34 35 okay so you've been married
what 10 years
yeah actually okay
now my wife we've been married 40 years
and my wife says we've had 33 good years
of marriage
um
and she's referring to the first seven
when her voice didn't get heard that's
how I recognize this stuff so quickly
because I'm you many years ago okay and
um and and so one of the here's the
skills that Sharon and I had to learn
number one I had to slow down and listen
proverbs 31 says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband
safely trusts her and he will have no
lack of gain
I used to do a lot of what you did here
which is half listen half let her talk
and then I go and did what I wanted to
do
and that's what you did and so you need
to own that she also needs to own the
fact that she was being too freaking
timid
and she needs to freaking speak up
I mean she you know
she may have hate well no no you don't
know no I'm listen you are I don't know
I wouldn't put that on her I'm putting
it on both of them and communication
style sucks okay you all did not talk up
through a major life thing where both of
you were heard because she didn't speak
loud enough and you didn't shut up long
enough
and those both of the both of you got to
work on that and if you don't I mean
Sharon and I had to work on it it took
us a long time and uh we're now we
loudly communicate and often so uh but
the uh you know it's a good hillbilly
fight sometimes but at least we both get
heard and I have a rule I do not move
forward on major decisions of any kind
especially financial decisions without
sharing completely looking at me and
saying okay I'm heard I I have some
concerns I've talked about them but I
think we need to go ahead I hear what
you're saying and we come to Total
agreement both having voiced our thing
and so what does he do start something I
think you go back and you apologize but
you need to own what you did here she
needs to own and then say okay now what
do you want to do
you want me to go in and quit the job
that I've accepted
or do you want to make the move and if
the move goes bad
and it's horrible then we can make
another move if we have to
that would actually be my suggestion is
remember that this is maybe not forever
uh it feels like to her it's absolute
and there's no going back and she's
especially since families there and
everything it's like you're about to go
plant roots is what it you know what it
kind of feels like but giving her the
Dignity of the option of like hey if
this goes bad and we're not enjoying it
and give it a year we'll come back or
we'll go another place yeah
but yeah you gotta own the fact you
didn't listen and change the home the
fact she didn't speak up and then y'all
got to decide what you're going to do
before Monday don't wander off up there
while this isn't a fog this is not going
to go well you need Clarity yeah before
you do this essentially moving my
suggestion would be that both of you own
your part in this horrible communication
plan you have and address that for the
future and go ahead and take the job and
I suggest she goes along with that with
the caveat that we could leave in a year
if it doesn't work that's what I would
do
so but you're gonna have to give her an
out man you didn't get you didn't listen